it's estimated that around a hundred
thousand britons are currently in spain
and after learning that they'll have to
spend two weeks in quarantine
when they return home many of them are
angry
they've given us basically no notice of
this i know they have to have a
have to have some sort of a line drawn
but they've not given anybody a chance
some people's jobs may depend
on them getting back to work next week
from the holiday that was green lighted
by the uk government
the self-isolating britons will include
the minister
whose department announced the latest
holiday misery
transport secretary grant shaps it's
understood he traveled to spain for a
holiday yesterday
his officials say he'll stay for the
duration and self-isolate on his return
to the uk
as required back at heathrow airport
the lucky ones who arrived back in the
uk from spain
just before the midnight deadline were
relieved but also frustrated
i met my mum and dad and my sister out
there
and they're still there now it's a
matter of hours
we couldn't get on the same flight so
they're going to have to
self-isolate and i won't which is
obviously up for debate it's a sharp
rise in coronavirus cases in spain
and warnings of a second wave that have
led to it being dropped from the
government's travel corridors exemption
list
under the new rules travelers arriving
into england wales scotland and northern
ireland
from spain and its islands will need to
self-isolate for two weeks
people already in spain can stay for the
rest of their holiday
but will have to self-isolate on their
return
and the foreign office is advising
against all but essential travel
to mainland spain the tipping point is
new data um received about the level of
disease in spain
particularly on the mainland and one of
the things that we
always have to be prepared for in this
pandemic
is i'm afraid that things can change
very quickly
and things have changed quite remarkably
fast in spain and that is the reason why
we do not wish to delay
the government is urging employers to be
understanding
those returning from spain who now won't
be able to go back to work
for 14 days john craig sky news